the crime never stops yet the left
blames cops
time for a new installment of the left
thinks you're as dumb as
they are
welcome back to the left thinks you're
as dumb as they are i'm your host
barbara streisand
first up former obama appointee and
grown adult britney packet cunningham
who thinks rising crime rates is the
cops fault
i think that there are a lot of police
unions and gop operatives
that would like for us to believe that
this recent crime wave has everything to
do with this idea of defunding the
police
so this rising crime is not the fault of
the movement
it's actually the fault of the police
and this has been our point all along
why should we keep funding systems and
institutions that keep rendering
themselves
ineffective that made no sense but
that's one vote for it's the cops fault
but if you ask the white house it's the
gun's fault
the president's expected to lay out an
anti-crime strategy this week focusing
on gun crimes as a way to slow the
country's
rise in homicides but for an answer on
why guns are suddenly being used more
often
we'll have to wait for biden's next
press conference sometime in
2030. just don't ask liberal media
outlets like cnn
consider this headline seven killed more
than 40 injured in 10 mass shootings
across the u.s over the weekend but a
closer look reveals many of these crimes
were spontaneous and possibly
gang-related not pre-ordained mass
shootings
lumping those together shifts the blame
from defunding police
to gun control but hey at least they
aren't pretending it's peaceful
you know it reminds me of what thomas
jefferson once said
greg can you pull down your shades the
children can see everything you're doing
thomas jefferson my neighbor upstate not
the president
about that it's tommy it's tommy i threw
me off for a second but i had met him
this happens all the time mercedes it's
embarrassing for me
they changed the language in the in the
categories
so now it's just going to be about the
gun and they're doing it and
the media plays along because they agree
i thought they were going to roll out
beto o'rourke as the guns are when was
that going to happen did he make the
promise to nato
god could you imagine yeah you know
they're getting a child
when and the other point is are they
going to go with the buy-back program at
some point that's something that kamala
is very passionate about we know that
guns are not the problem law abiding
citizens
should be able to carry their their
their
weapons and their guns um and quite
frankly what we're seeing in these blue
states
is the fact that there they have the
most restrictions yet we see the most
violence in
these states and in these cities i don't
think a criminal has ever walked up to a
buy-back program it said here's my gun
here's my home address and could you put
make it out to caitlyn
prime in california is pretty bad it's
horrible yeah what uh
how would you address that that that
spike well first of all
um in los angeles county i live in los
angeles county alex dolan nueva
is the head of the sheriff's department
and he just recently lowered standards
for concealed carry yeah that was
beautiful
i know what i am 100 yeah
with that uh also in texas abbott did
the same thing
uh unfortunately and you could just see
the press conference that he had
it's like he didn't want to do it but
you know what we need an armed citizenry
yeah yeah and and so he did it and i
think that's a good thing
and so um i am you know pro-gun
all the way i wouldn't have guessed it
well i've always been on the you know
the uh the republican side i've always
i i have a gun at my house i i go to the
shooting range i have a lot of fun doing
it it's a lot of fun oh it is a lot of
fun what do you have
uh i just have a little nine millimeter
glock 17. nine millimeters my favorite
i have a tactical shotgun which i enjoy
cat what about you
what is the what you're we talk about
crime every day and
it feels like we're in a bubble that we
can't reach the people who are in
control
i feel like nobody can reach anyone else
which is
really strange because even though we're
really divided on many things i think
that's something that
you know pretty much everyone can agree
on is that we don't want to get shot
and or stabbed yes so it shouldn't be so
divisive but
the problem is when you have all these
false narratives of oh it's not that bad
or oh it's just a talking point when
really
you know poll after poll shows that most
americans they want
accountability for police that do the
wrong things but they don't want to get
rid of police they want to be protected
it shouldn't be that hard
so we keep i guess electing people who
don't understand nuance or don't
understand
you know how to evaluate reality for
what it is you know tyres it is the
it is the challenge when one party
labels any kind of law and order as
anti-compassionate
right that's what you run into no matter
what if you come out strong
they're gonna say that you're like a
bully a bully yeah listen i
um this is i'm just one of my roles on
this show is
just keep it real yeah what i'm saying
because i'm really good about getting
fired and finding new jobs
[Laughter]
in the spirit of that yes when
is somebody i guess it's me just gonna
say it's not the guns it's not
people are bad human beings
are rotten we lie we cheat we steal we
kill each other
we rape we pillage human beings do this
yes the only way to stop it is by
putting the bad
human beings away you want to blame you
want to take the police money away
you want to take guns out of hand the
whole point of the right to bear arm is
to protect us from what
bad humans yes that's it you know we
like to put it
paint it pretty and say it's in case the
government we can form a militia
no we have to form melissa's now because
of bad
human beings they're horrible i've never
done anything
literally getting to the point where i
guess it's good for me tyrus
why did you kill everybody in the house
they was home
defense reps that's where we're going
that is true that that that wasn't as
bad as i thought i thought
okay hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else